they're the serious versions of us
just what we need to check us up a notch
let's prove we are the best Titans in
the multiverse
so I think I know who's behind this
hi there that's right we will conquer
the multiverse together and there's
nothing you can do to stop us we are in
the danger it is time for the
cooperation come on
oh wow yeah we're all besties now
Oh what took you so long
Santa Claus
is this good or bad
the cost of being a hero brooding heroes
there Robin is so handsome
[Music]
Titans go
they need to know we're still here this
is the Teen Titans can anyone hear us we
think we found a way back hey everybody
it's Charlie I got a bunch of requests
to do a video for this new Teen Titans
trailer explaining what's going on when
it's gonna drop because it's basically
them doing their version of spider-man
into the spider verse so this is the
closest we're getting to Teen Titans
season 6 sort of continuing their story
within now a new interconnected universe
of animated TV series so they're
canonizing all this stuff they almost
did the same thing with spider-man into
the spider verse because Tom Holland was
going to cameo as a version of his Peter
Parker from the MCU in that animated
movie so if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the DC
Easter Egg videos
Comic Con is coming up in July they're
gonna be dropping trailers for
everything including titans season -
we're getting Batman and a whole bunch
of characters all explained that stuff
at the end of the video including the
crisis on Infinite Earths crossover
later this year so if you're not sure
what's going on there was a post-credits
teaser during Teen Titans go to the
movies for the original Teen Titans
animated series saying we think we found
a way to come back and everybody was a
little confused about what was going on
like okay well they're bringing the
original Teen Titans back that's really
nostalgic that's gonna be really cool
but when are we actually gonna see that
now we actually know the premise is
basically them being pulled into a
battle arena battle world style if you
want to think about Marvel's Secret Wars
to fight the characters from Teen Titans
go which now I guess are from an
alternate universe but the really meta
thing is is that it's all the same voice
actors doing the exact same characters
when they cancelled the original Teen
Titans animated series back in 2006
basically what they did is they just
completely redid all the characters and
turned it into Teen Titans go but they
kept all the same voice actors voicing
the exact same characters this is the
official synopsis which gives you a
better idea for what's actually going on
during the movie because the premise is
them just fighting each other but
obviously it's a much bigger story than
that
it says the comedic modern-day
quintet takes on their 2003 counterparts
when villains from each of their worlds
joined forces to pit the two titan teams
against each other as you saw during the
trailer that's basically the two trigons
are the big bosses Trigon from the
original Teen Titans and then Trigon
from Teen Titans go still need to set
aside their differences and work
together to combat Trigon hexagon Santa
Claus the synopsis actually reads yes
that's right Santa Claus in time itself
in order to save the universe as you can
see from the animation style Santa Claus
is a Teen Titans go character just
because that serious tends to be way
more ridiculous
I've only kept up with that series as
much as I needed to to understand what
Easter eggs they were referencing or if
they did callbacks to the original
animated series you'll also remember
they did the exact same thing that
they're doing during this movie with the
Young Justice characters a couple years
ago Teen Titans go vs the Young Justice
characters if we can't be serious about
being superheroes and who
[Music]
those real send these cretins to our
base in the croteau and nebula for
further interrogation something tells me
this is only the beginning
that is some serious hero work Titans
Aqualad
we came here to clean up your mess but
it looks like you have everything under
control perhaps you can admit you
misjudged us you do look pretty serious
now I just worry is it too serious let's
get out of here
Titans there's a life-and-death
emergency in the Mucca Mucca sector we
have to deal with and something tells me
this is only the beginning I've already
done a couple videos about why they
canceled that original Teen Titans
animated series because it was heavily
serialized it was way more dramatic in
the network's target demographic was
much younger children who had trouble
following that so they turned it into a
show for really young kids so that's how
we wound up with Teen Titans go and as
funny as it is to see them try to
canonize all these different shows in
the same multiverse of animated series
together they actually kind of backdoor
canonised the original Teen Titans
animated series in a previous episode of
Teen Titans go when they're remembering
the events of the cliffhanger every boot
of the Teen Titans once before look upon
your previous incarnation that looks
like us but better
these Teen Titans were about character
development drama and heart I used to be
so much cooler I want to watch
[Music]
all
Oh
whoa
[Music]
what that's how it is and there is no
six season to resolve the plots hanging
from the cliff you ended that show you
monster this is taking place after the
events of the Teen Titans cliffhanger at
the end of season 5 so think of this
effectively as the Teen Titans Season 6
story within this shared big crossover
event the actual release date for this
movie seems like it's going to be
sometime later this year after comic-con
because the next animated movie that DC
is dropping is gonna be Batman hush
that's gonna be right after Comic Con so
I'm guessing a couple months after that
is when this is gonna drop sometime
during the holiday shopping season there
been rumors that they're already
planning on doing a sequel to this which
would make sense if they're trying to go
spider-man into the spider-verse with it
because those movies are spawning a
whole bunch of sequels in themselves
they're already doing a spider-gwen
movie they're already working on the
direct sequel so why wouldn't DC do the
same thing with its animated movies but
the other big news is the Titan season
two is gonna be starting later this year
in October sometime around the same time
season 1 premiered they'll be dropping
trailers for that at Comic Con in July
along with the crisis on Infinite Earths
arrowverse crossover shows like the
flash season 6 arrow season 8 I'll do as
many trailer videos as I can for that
but if you are a big Teen Titans fan
they are going full Teen Titans on Titan
season 2 they just cast Batman it's
gonna be Jorah Mormont's so it'll be a
slightly older version of Batman Jason
Todd is a series regular meaning that
he's gonna be in most of the episodes
they're doing a new version of
Deathstroke that's not Manu Bennett but
they're doing rose Wilson ravager
Jericho Conner Kent Superboy and crypt
so and the Garth version of Aqualad they
said they'd be doing a version of the
Judas contract storyline probably using
rose Wilson Ravager and Jericho instead
of Terra but Terra could always become a
character on the TV show eventually
pretty safe bet that in pursuit of a
Batman under the Red Hood storyline to
that they'll have Deathstroke wound up
killing Jason Todd and then future
possible seasons after that introducing
Rachele Ghul the Lazarus pits for his
eventual resurrection if they're gonna
do a version of Batman you might as well
pull on that thread so maybe they'll
also use that as the path to Talia al
Ghul and damian wayne in the live-action
universe if you're a big fan of Young
Justice that's coming back next week
they're going to air all the rest of the
episodes from the back half of season 3
next Tuesday will be episodes 14 15 and
16 dropping on Tuesday then the rest of
the episodes will air once per week
until they air the rest of them which is
26 that means that the finale for season
3 is gonna be during August they have
not announced a season 4 yet so there
are pretty good odds that if they wind
up folding the DC Universe streaming
service into that larger Warner Brothers
streaming service next year there is the
danger that it would get cancelled I
think just depending on how the rest of
the episodes perform but I'll probably
do a new Young Justice video sometime
soon too so I'll try to explain what's
going on with the future of Young
Justice when I do that they're working
on an animated Batman the long Halloween
movie which makes sense they just did
Batman hush of course they're gonna do
the long Halloween at some point and
supposedly they're using that storyline
as the basis for the new live-action
Batman trilogy with Robert Pattinson the
long Halloween and dark victory so I
know there's a whole bunch of stuff
going on just let me know what you want
me to do in and around Comic Con in the
next couple of weeks in terms of
trailers and teasers for all the big
stuff that's coming up I'm working on a
new Rick and Morty season 4 video and
then I have my New Avengers end game
post-credit scene and deleted scenes
from that extended cut that video will
post tomorrow morning while you wait for
everything click here for my
non-spoilery spider-man far from home
review and click here for that
taskmaster vs. Black Widow teaser for
the new avengers endgame prequel movie
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]